付油價代表的就是
我加油會退錢嗎
現在加油有多亢
送血針雜誌一份
大家的油槽都滿了
你必須要接收500桶原油
就是我付錢給你來把油搬走
本土小鋼炮
對上外資長槍
台電在那天開法書
外資買6萬張
中石屋在那天很很的到給他
這段節目之後看完之後
你可能就不想追外資了
就外資不好用
台灣的比較好用
厲害
小哥 我們今天有新的
我們的重磅級萊丁加入
就是我們莫華哥
你知道為什麼莫華哥會回來嗎
你看他都沒有戴護目鏡
對
也沒戴口罩
對 代表他想要跟我們非常親密
今天兩位都開車來嗎
我開車來
開車來對不對
我今天去加油
你之前都不想開車嗎
都想做大眾運輸工具
对啊 现在没办法 开车比较快
开车比较快 不是开车比较快
是开车会送东西
开车送机
开车加油送东西 应该这样讲
对 去加油就送机车嘛 是不是
加油就送机车
因为现在不是史上首见的富有价吗
富有价
好 那你去也是送机车吗
我今天去还没送
以后可能还会送 以后才会送
听说你是希望送比基尼女郎帮你洗车
对 那就不错啦
是不是
这我就满意了
好 各位观众
欢迎收看今天的理财达人秀
今天达人秀蓬毕生辉
为什么
除了我们平常的全镇小哥
我们今天还来到一个
总经界的大师
慕华哥
那双哥来要干什么
当然是双哥有仇必报
那今天要爆料什么呢
大家都知道最近付邮价
付邮价到底什么意思呢
加油会送东西吗
加油会贴钱给你吗
没有那么好
而且穆华哥会告诉我们
其实富油价代表世界经济出大事
不过不要担心
因为小哥会在筹码上告诉你
最近什么事情很强
本土的资金大胜外资资金
所以今天如果大家对
你手上的持股会有点担心
你对富油价的世界会有点忧虑
别怕别怕
因为本土的资金比较强
会来教你怎么样抓到有一些筹码是
本土的力量远胜外资
但是我们要先来问穆华哥了
对 因为最近的油价
让大家看不懂
那因为呢
其实像赵华呢
虽然也是常常会在看油价
可是我还真不知道
今天这个负油价
代表的就是
我加油会退钱吗
事实上基本上
当然不可能加油没急
但是现在加油战真的苦哈哈
我已经帮大家
窥焊到一件事情
什么事
就是现在加油有好坎
什么好坎
我会送机车啦
刚刚讲的是开玩笑
来 我帮大家窥断道
看这个就归来
大家看到这个地方有没有
加油话可以送写真杂志一本
哎呦
我冲了这个我就去加油了
冲了这个去加油吗
拿到什么拿到什么
来看一下
快窥密一下
写真杂志一本怎么样
你认真
正不正
我跟你讲我派记者去查过了
好
莫哥你这个就输我了
不是送那个
那个太弱了
那是送什么
真正是送这个来
送这个来
好不好
对啦
物物骨片大写
我们接你一下
这个是加油的动力就没有了
不会啊
我们也回家
这个也可以看一天
对不对
好啦
我们来看一下
什么叫做负油价
很多人听不懂
我们来解释一下
到底有没有可能
我们去加油
真的可以
不用钱来加油
事实上当然不可能
各位看到
我们从经济部网站上
调出来的资料
大家可以看到
基本上油它含的成本
固定成本
有没有一个税前的批售价
假设说是零元
油价已经跌到零了
对不对
货务税至少还要6.83
然后石油基金要0.13
然后土污费要0.01
空污费还有加油站的毛利
万万税的感觉
对啊
所以说再怎么样说
乘以5%的营业税
每一公升都还要将近11块
每一公升11块
不过现在油价也是一字头
在它们加油
而且下个礼拜
就我们节目播出的下一周
那油价还要再降一块
再降一块钱
再降一块
我现在这个车子
我的车大概可以加50公升
我现在去加油
不用一张1000块
以前最贵的时候
我还记得大概要1400 1500
下礼拜你又再省50块
下礼拜要省50块
所以真的是非常的厚康
那当然油价下跌
可能很多人讲说很厚康
加油很便宜
但问题是来了
现在车上路上
刚刚小哥不讲说
现在开车很快吗
路上車多嗎
現在路上車不多
而且車商的供貨
也有斷鏈的問題
所以說低油價
或者說負窯價
它所曝露出來的背面的
一個很重大因素
就是全世界經濟很差
就是很慘對不對
現在莫華哥告訴我們的是
我們前面歡樂過了
但現在我們要沉重一下下
所以大家看這個地方
負油價的主要原因是什麼
第一個全世界原油需求衰退
那趙華為什麼需求會衰退
你飞机都不开了
油轮也不能了
上面公主都已经昏倒了
你知道现在多夸张吗
夸张到所有船船
他们现在的乘客数
大概是以前正常的
差不多3%而已
那以前我们很浪漫
会去看飞机从天上飞过去
情侣约会的地点
现在在那边约很久
飞机都不会飞过去
没错
第二个原因就是原油期货结算
所以油没地方放
我们刚不是讲吗
一口 你做一口
1000桶到500桶
所以不要开玩笑
大家以为赚了一口
结果1000桶油送到你家
我讲一个实际的例子
美国原油库存是不是标到新高
对
这个库存标上来代表什么
代表根本没有需求
没有需求
所以再减产也没用
减产一点点而已
对啊
那你知道美国的油都放在哪里
美国最主要有好几个重要的除油的地方
你就说那个油不是从油井挖出来之后
它不是要放在那个油槽里面
比如像各位看到這個照片
這個照片就是一個個的油槽
它就是要放在這種油槽
比如說各位到外木山 基隆那邊
這個從情人谷那樣下去
然後如果你從情人谷那邊開車
要開到基隆 你可以走到外木山
外木山那邊就有這個很多中油的除草
就在海邊 我們觀眾朋友一定看過
所以現在他們也是滿的就對了
趙華你都沒有回應
就代表你沒有去過那邊
沒有 我沒有 我現在很久沒約會了
因為你沒有情人 對不對
不是 軟哥你要約我啊
不然都小哥約我
下車開車帶你去外木山
情人谷那邊逛一逛
見識一下什麼叫做除油槽
現在很危險那邊除滿了油
要是有人丟一顆
那邊油可能都已經在漏出來
滿地都在漏
沒有看到那個油管接到海裡面去
在漏出來因為太滿了
開玩笑
這個地方叫庫星
庫星是美國奧克拉河馬州
全北美還不是只有美國最大的除油基地
另外很大一個儲油基地
就在墨西哥灣沿岸
那我們就講酷薪就好
酷薪最滿最滿
它可以存7500萬桶
7500萬桶
對 好 這個很大的量對不對
是北美最大的儲油基地
你知道現在已經存多少了嗎
存多少
現在已經存到6100萬桶了
那還好啊 木華哥
剩下1500萬桶對不對
對
好 那我告訴你
它每一週的儲進去的量
現在是600萬桶
快滿了
三個禮拜就滿了
也就是說各位
再三個禮拜照這個趨勢發展下去
你會看到酷薪油槽全滿
對 他就要蓋成101大樓
這個圖表就是這樣子不可能蓋因為他已經是滿到了喉嚨了所以说现在目前就是因为大家的油槽都满了所以说为什么会造成负油价
因为当天这个要结算
所以说大家就必须要把
那个期货卖出来
那卖出来免得食物交割
因为也没地方放
酷薪也满了
很多地方都满了
而且现在存放的价格也非常的高
每天都在涨
所以怎么办
只好忍痛杀
杀到负37块
这样大家懂了吗
就是我付钱给你来把油搬走
对 我付钱
我一口付将近40块美金
给你把这1000桶请你运走
所以说你不要以为说
这个是真的付油价
其实不是啦
它只是一个金融交易的结果
实物上面我们的现货油价还是正的
也就是说你现在要去买油
你要跟沙尔地亚拉伯买
你要跟油商买油
大概一桶都还要在
10块钱左右的油价
还是要花钱啦
对
但是刚才沐华哥有点到嘛
现在最夯的就是要把油运走这件事情
没错
那运油要靠什么
运油的话就几个管道
输油管对不对
那走陆地上
那另外走海上靠什么
我们叫Super Tank
二月中的时候
这种超级油轮
一天的租金是三万美金
三万美金
它有不同航线
大概平均三万美金
你知道现在一天涨到多少吗
多少
最贵的航线涨到三十万美金
十倍
它的受贿概念
一般的航線漲到20萬美金
大家可以看到就是這個VLCC
叫Very Large Crew Carrier
Very Large Crew Carrier意思就是超級大郵輪
超級大超級大
你看它這個紅色線這樣飆上來
有沒有恐怖
就代表什麼運價大幅的攀升
所以它是受惠族群對不對
它是受惠族群
所以台灣有一家航運公司
就有三艘超級大郵輪
這個2605的新興航運
所以聽說木華哥有賺到嗎
跑了
跑了 人家超級大
你不能超級多
因為基本上我覺得
這也都是短線行情而已
這個油價下來之後
他們大概也就沒有那麼好的行情
所以基本上大家就是做
我覺得等一下問小哥
小哥比較厲害
來各位看一下這個
油商會不會倒閉呢
趙華你覺得後面油商會不會倒閉
我覺得會啦
因為現在已經低於很多油商的
生產成本價嘛
那我跟大家讲油商还没倒闭
交易商先倒闭
你没有看到这两天新闻
中信金控踩雷了
27亿新台币踩到新加坡倒闭的
最大的亚洲的油的交易商
新龙集团
所以它会有一些联动效应到
国内有一些股票
可能跟这件事情有关
没错
中信金还算小咖
因为它9千万美金
最大苦主是谁你知道吗
上海汇丰银行6亿美金
借给这家公司
圈倒
所以这种风暴
其实搞不好会像当年的
联动债这种感觉
对不对
没错
踩到联动下去
你不要想说油价跌
好像跟我无关
事实上油价跌
它会牵扯到非常多的连锁反应
跟牵扯到非常多的行业
好 那我们再来看
大型石油公司的股价
现在是不是己无幸存
你可以看到标普
这个都是最大型的石油公司
最深的跌到70%
少一点的也跌到20%
30%
艾克森美孚石油公司的股价
今年都腰斬了
你看这个跌幅是非常惊人
现在这些公司所有市值加起来
只有微软的一半
不过莫华哥
我一直在看那个能源基金
因为他们也会买这些大型石油公司
所以赵华还是有点想抄底
好那抄底我是觉得再等一等
可能再等一两个月的时间
现在还不宜了
因为这档这个ETF就是抄底的结果
这个是全世界最大的原油ETF
叫USO
大家应该有听过
对不对
你可以看到它今年初是13块
跌到这一波
跌到剩下2块
那当然跟台湾有关的
就是原石油的正二
还有反一
有没有
反一飙涨4倍
正二跌到快要下市
正二有人在照顾
我们就不多聊了
对
所以说这种原油相关的投资标的
我个人是觉得
现在大家就是在场边
做人板凳
看一看就好
还不到下场的时候
好 不行啦 阮哥要我等
小哥我等不及
那刚好你来
对 每次你都可以
解决我的燃眉之急
对不对
你想要超油吗
我想要超油吗
没有啦 跟油
任何相关的或是便宜的
我都想超
那最好不要碰油
油太恐怖了
PD上面有个人
这个0.25块去超油
以为够便宜了吧
0.25有种跌到零啊
他不是掉里
他一直跌到负数
非常有种
对 对不对
我们来看一下这个
这叫原油筹码COT指数
那原油筹码COT指数是什么意思啊
就是投机的人扣掉避险的人
叫原油筹码COT
投机的人扣掉避险的人
对我们一般都是投机啊
那油商是避险
那投机扣掉避险的我们看到
这个以前在2010年前玩的很少
这十年来越玩越大
不过玩的时候还好
只要它的指數上漲
他們的部位就變多
指數上漲部位變多
都還好 順向交易
但是這一次 這次很特別
這次是它大跌的時候
它部位也變大
你知道為什麼嗎
因為一堆國家發行ETF
大家都在玩油
我前天問到我的營業員
遇到營業員 營業員跟我講
你知道嗎
每天 每天 每天
都有人問我怎麼買原油
因为他们起过公司嘛
这个我也有经验
对
因为这华公司也很多
每天每天每天不同部门的员工
问我怎么样投资原油
对
这就是一个信号
很恐怖
对
你在那天假如你下清原油的话
你在4月21号那天
礼拜一晚上
下清原油没法下
因为他隔天要交割
对
所以他前一天他把这个给关闭了
所以你下清原油
OK没事
对
下小型清原油可以下
当天晚上就结算
现金结算
让你跑都跑不了
然后跌到盘下的时候
你想要盘下我要停损
对
连停损都按不下去
这个比结婚还可怕
离婚都离不了
你不晓得后面有多惨
你知道吗
不晓得到底要跌到多少
这个听说回买价是-100
对
你要砍
只能砍-100
太恐怖了
所以有人可能花
有人说他花几千块去玩
最后赔了几百万
对
这个原有你要下单
在一笔至少要12万台币的保证金
再跌到37块的话
一口可以赔50几万
那10口呢
所以两位健在是
赵华觉得很开心的事情
没有我们很开心是我们都没有碰
对 我们没有下到
一下到就50几万
是被保证金
身为台股的股民对不对
沐华哥刚刚讲完
其实我会怕
因为全世界的景气看起来真的非常非常差
那說真的趙華也不敢去抄什麼原油的底
可是我想大家多多少好都有持有台股
說實話台股最近是世界第一名
很強
根本就領先指標
我們漲美股就得給我漲
美股跌我們不會跌
問題也不知道在搶什麼
不知道在搶什麼
等一下我們要來解密
我們有國家隊在後面
我們要來解密台股在搶什麼
所以到底我們現在
像趙華9200的時候
有買一些但是不多
可是現在我會有點近
有點擔心
我會有點近
我是不是剛才賣掉了
但是也沒有賺很多
我們來看一下
昨天的籌碼狀況
昨天的籌碼狀況昨天的籌碼狀況昨天的家群指數在這邊已經快要碰到季線了快要碰到季線我們看一下這個主力全台灣做股票主力在賣鈔
在賣鈔
外資也賣
我們上個禮拜講
只有投信在買
不是外資不是要認錯嗎
怎麼還是偷賣
外資他都買台子旗賣現股
之前在做套利
不過最近他的現股
這個也在出貨了
太子旗也在卖
所以这个要小心
那投信呢
这个之前都投信买
现在连投信也在卖
因为我们上礼拜有分析
其实投信是唯一筹码里面
他还勇敢站在买房的
因为有人在低档买了一堆0050、0056
那投信他避嫌去买点股票
对 好讲到我
好 不过他们这些人
我看最近他们可能买不下去了
那另外中石户
中石户就是主力扣掉三大法人
中石户也在卖
只有一个人做多
谁
散户
只有散户做多
不过散户做多
我们筹码我们要偏空看待
是
所以昨天是五大接空
五大接空
结果今天一开盘开高就杀低
就杀低
所以看来五大接空的杀伤力非同小可
对
但是筹码其实有异象
对不对
虽然五大接空
但是这一次
台湾不但防疫第一
国家之光
连我们的台股都是国家之光
对
我们来看一下这个台股
某一档股票
这档股票我们来讲一下
小兄你手都抖了你
实在太强了
我帮你拿
这档股票先不要讲他是谁
免得外资对他有提防
这档股票我们看他本土券商
我把这十年来
这十年来
区间获利前十名的本土券商
区间获利前十名的券商
列出來
好
只有一個外國人
新加坡瑞穎
新加坡商瑞穎
其他都是
台灣人
他不一定是外國人
他可能是台灣有人
入籍新加坡籍之後
在那邊操作
有道理
可能是台中
因為你看
這個幾乎都是
台中彰化的分點
其中第一名叫兆豐路港
他這10年來賺了6億多
厲害
他賺的錢誰賠的呢
我們看有第一名陪的叫摩根大通
陪五一六
對
第二名原副
之後還有香港上海匯豐
台灣匯立
港商野村
台灣摩根史丹利
後面還有一堆
小哥
這張就是我們的驕傲
加一加
這個我們叫做本土義和團
本土義和...
不是
本土小鋼炮
對上外資長槍
對上八國聯軍
八國聯軍
把他們殺的這個...
對
不是義和團
不能讲义和团
义和团是输的
我们很厉害的 不是义和团
好 那这个外资呢
其实在交易上
其实都做得没有很好
没有很好
我们来看这个昨天很红的那两个股票
没有很好 我们听他的干嘛
一天大晚都在报外资
对啊 很多人都看外资
其实你看完这段节目之后
看完之后
你可能就不想追外资了
就外资
肉脚
不好用
对 不好用
我们要看中石库
好用
台湾的比较好用
厉害 好
好 来看这个华星科
你看他昨天涨停
可是外资其实
我们看到
这外资其实很短
什么
很短线
外资都是长的
对
他也有短的
真的吗
有短的
我以前听到外资都是长的
都是长的
外资有短的
小哥看的比较多
我看比较短
我真的看蛮多的
我可以跟你讲个笑话
好
真的
笑话是这样子
我有一次去夏威夷
对 夏威夷
对 杜蜜月的时候去夏威夷
夏威夷的时候刚刚我在上厕所
对 隔壁老外上厕所
不小心瞄了
哇 上面有刺青啊
老外上面有刺青 写WA
那里有刺青就对了
那里有刺青
哇 我就哇 哇
WA就是哇嘛
对 我就哇
我说哇 你这刺青这个哇
哇 我问他什么意思啊
他说哇 是不好意思
他就把他那个弄长一点给我看
叫 Welcome to America
歡迎來到美國
所以其實外資平常看的時候是短的
有的是短的 有的是長的
那小哥你沒有反拉一些給他看嗎
Welcome to Taiwan之類的
他很短線
所以很短線的股票很容易怎麼樣
很容易今天搶了明天就弱了
沒動堂
沒動堂 今天搶明天弱
那这张股票呢 都是谁在买
都是散户在买
所以散户它还是有发挥功效
对 散户最近把它买上来
对 只是持久力比较差一点
这种散户买上来的后面都要很小心
对 那我们再来看这个
台湾之光 台积电
台积电 富国神机
这很厉害哦
对 富国神机呢
它在什么时候这个外资大卖呢
你看一下 在低点的时候外资大卖
真的耶
这不是卖错了吗
肉脚
对啊
不过我必须说
因为也有认识一些台积电的人
他们对自己公司
其实没有很乐观
他们对景气的看法
其实跟慕华哥会差不多
觉得其实景气
可能有很大的衰退
可是没有想到
股价就这样上去了
对
那他们其实没有很乐观
在低档
台湾人
中食物还是在买
厉害耶
厉害他们抄底
中食物抄底
然后散户是一路买
散户一路买
散户也厉害啊
散户高档买低档也买
散户都在买
存股嘛
一直存一直存
这个是一种情感
一种情感
对 国家之光
那这个台积电在那天开法说
是
开完之后外资呢
买六万张
对
回补
认错回补
对
然后呢
中时务在那一天呢
恨恨的道给他
厉害吧
小哥整戒
因为很多人手上有台积电哦
我们当然要跟着中石户嘛
不能跟外资
外资的单不能跟
因为外资呢
他们比的是相对绩效
他们不是比说我今天赔多少赚多少
不是
他比如说我比老王赚多少还是赔多少
比隔壁老王
跟隔壁的外资比
他们比的相对绩效
主要是比排名
只要排名高就可以了
那外资常常追高杀低
例如说我们看友达
有的他在这个高档
在这个高档外资继续追
然后中石屋在这个高档大卖
大卖给他
散户高档有卖
现在跌下来散户又买
所以这档散户做得还不错
散户做得还不错
这档散户在高档有卖
值得称赞的对不对
对可能因为是他啦
散户真的不敢报太久
所以我们大部分看散户
散户有时候做得不错
那外资大部分都做得蛮差的
因为散户其实会有经验值
因为有的股票会有所谓的credit嘛
没错
所以你有时候买它
散户也学聪明了
知道不要搞太久
好 不要搞太久
好 我们再看红海
红海也是很多散户爱的股票
可是红海我们看
在高点的时候外资拼命追
是
中食物拼命到
对
散户也到给外资
那等到第一档下来的时候
外资就到货
所以外资追高杀低
所以这一档也是本土资金
大勝外資
就是土炮對洋炮
土炮勝對不對
對 每次都是土炮勝
這一檔我們同事
非常多人在問耶
你說這檔對啊那個鴻海當然啦鴻海我是覺得你不要碰他不是 現在我们土炮都赢了然后你还是觉得不要碰他这一档从我们节目开播两年来
郭董已经开始买他自己的股票了
买了四千张了
所以穆华哥觉得还是不要碰吗
没有啦
上一次郭董要连买六个月
要买连买六个月
股票才涨上去
你的意思是现在开始买
至少要等半年
上一次经验就那样啊
就刚刚小哥那一波啊
拉上去最高那一波
就是郭董先前
买了半年之后就拉上去
对 这边买了以后拉上去
对 他总共买了六个月
所以布局要半年
是这个意思
那现在刚开始买
对 所以你就往后推半年
就是鸿海的买点
跟着郭董存股
非常明确
小哥 你要拿出一些例子来
就是我们有给外资
一点颜色瞧瞧
颜色瞧瞧
我们来看一下这个人保
好 人保大股票
对 各位看一下
这个低点呢
这个低点都是他在卖的
外资在卖
外资在卖 这边
就这样把低点的地方卖掉了
然后中石户在买
不过最近啊
最近可能要小心一点
因为最近的中石户转为卖超
只有昨天有稍微买一点
不过这个长时间看起来在卖
因为我也听说他们内部人有讲
说其实订单很满
只是出货有点状况
因为断链的问题
所以订单是好的
很乐观
但是出不了货
所以之后应该很多产业都有这个问题
都有这个问题
会有断链的问题
所以订单的乐观不是真的乐观
要注意
好 接下来我们看第二档
世界先进
也算大股票
也大股票
外资也是砍在低点
好奇怪 为什么
外资都追高杀低
然后中食物也是买在低点
不过最近呢
这个谈上来之后
最近中实物也在出了
要小心了
那除了这两个要小心以外
我们来讲正在买的
正在买
这个是历史验证
历史验证
就是本土的资金真的远胜外资
远胜外资
好我们来看一下这个中实物
也是胜外资的
和论企业
最近正在买
和论
各位看一下
中实物最近在买
对
可是外资在到货
所以小哥我
我懂暗号了
不要去追
你可以观察就好
核温7月我们都会想说
它租车的
租车最近声音应该很差
因为大家都不敢出去玩
本来零确诊就是有了一线生机
但是最近因为你知道军舰事件
所以大家就害怕了起来
它应该伤害很大才对
它应该很大
可是我们看它其实上个月的YY还正的
M2还增加21%
厉害喔
代表有些人不敢坐车
宁愿租车
这也是一个商机
租车比较安全
但总之筹码面上
它现在是在转强
没错
除了这以外
我们再看一下
这个最近油价跌
油价跌就容易上瘦下肥
就是上油比较瘦一点
这个利润比较少
下油因为成本变便宜了
所以像这个长芯化工
外资也是砍在低点
真的很妙
到现在还在砍
可是本土法人在这边
中石户就一路的大买了
这边差好多
买很多
这个的话我们观众朋友
也可以注意了
我们可以来留意说
到底这个本土资金
是不是买了之后
股价后续表现怎么样
因为这边要讲
我们不是说
今天小哥帮你筛出来后
就是叫你买
千万不要这样想
是在教你判断
看看是不是中石户买
外资买
反而中石户是赢的
好我们再来看下一档
那这一档也是实施库长股
它有实施库长股
后生
那实施库长股的分点
在永丰金的某分点
也是关键分点
关键分点
那关键分点各位看一下
这个底部呢
这底部的时候
其实关键分点买很多
中石户也买很多
这太戏剧性了吧
对
外资卖那么大
对 外资都砍在低点
中石户买在低点
买这么多
那现在弹起来之后
中石户继续买
因为它库长股嘛
所以库长股继续买超
好
这就符合小哥讲的
公司自己的大股东是很看好的
但是外资搞不好不懂他们好在哪里
对
那这个它有些的产业跟石油有点关系
也算石油的下油
也算是受惠于说油价下跌的话
油价下跌
它可以可能成本减轻
嗯 没错
好 希望大家来观察一下
好的
小哥我们来看看你的预测准不准确
我们来看它之后的股价状况
对
用看着就好
不要跟了 不要追
不是叫大家买
大家做做功课好不好
如果觉得小哥这样方法非常适用的话
你是一辈子受用
那慕华哥怎么看
好 那土洋对座
最近有一档股票
非常值得密切观察
一档
没有推荐 只要大家观察
对 其实大家观察
大家真的要记得看节目
不是叫你买股票
要学方法
就是说我们观察这一波
到底外资会不会胜出
今年外资买股票
买最用力的一档股票
当然不是说只有这档股票
外资其实也有买蛮多股票
但这档它是买得非常用力
这档股票叫做智邦
哎呦 外资买得非常用力
对啊 你去看外资
可是外资不是都输
你现在讲外资买非常用力
所以啊 智邦能不能涨上去
就是外资会不会赢啊
对不对
所以说能不能替外资洗血污名啊
就是说外资到底这是能不能战胜啊
因为看到智邦最近股价非常波动
它在200块大幅的洗刷
对
那外資從這個今年1月
一路買智邦買到現在
每天買超喔
每天都是在買超排行榜上面
鼎鼎有名的股票
沒有一天賣超
一路買你知道它買多少嗎
智邦它在年初的時候
籌碼庫存30萬張
到現在已經34萬張了
買了4萬張智邦
所以說我一直在盯智
智邦這張股票就是說
看看外資到底能不能勝出
好 我覺得你給我一個靈感
穆華哥給我一個靈感
我觉得现在观看的观众朋友
你都要去做一件事情
木槽哥说外资再买
那小哥说如果外资再买
中石户再出的话
那可能会是中石户赢
最近志邦有一点味道是外资再买
但是有可能中石户再出
为什么你知道
因为他在创新高
那这几天就这个礼拜
他股票震荡的非常大
多空大地战
没问题
功课交给观众去查
对 大家可以去观察
我们要出功课给观众做
观众可以自己去观察
我们就不预判
那观众他自己看完后
就知道智邦
200多块如果是下去
也是很有肉
所以大家要赶快去看一下
好 所以今天的理财达人秀
说实话我们是良心节目
怎么说呢
当世界的景气
真的有一种浓浓的危机感的时候
我们也是要告诉大家
但是如果大家觉得
短线上你还是很看好某些股票
请记得小哥教你的
看一下中时户的筹码
有没有持续在买进
刚才沐华哥有帮大家
出了一个功课
请大家做一下
外资有买进某一档股票吗
那你们可以去看一下
中石户它是在买还是在卖
来验证兼教你的方法
有没有用
那今天理财答案秀就到这边了
我们下礼拜再见咯
拜拜
在这么多好的老师
来教我们的理财答案秀
千万不要忘记我们有精英班
所以喜欢我们的内容的话
记得到理财答案秀的
YouTube频道
去订阅我们的精英班
或是按这边 按这边
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜